i learned long ago that being myself
was much easier than pretending to be
barbara walters
he works more hours than i do he works
six days a week at 88 years old
i had like this existential crisis i was
about 12 years old or something and
and i was like what does the world mean
want to be happy
build a life not just a business
[Music]
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you
know you're capable of more you've got
michael jordan level genius at something
so today let's live your best believe
life and learn how billionaires think
and get some success advice from the top
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one be yourself with oprah winfrey
there has to be some way that this
darkness
can be banished with light
says the man whose little boy
was massacred on just an ordinary friday
in december
so whether you call it soul or spirit
or higher self intelligence
there is i know this there's a light
inside each of you all of us
that illuminates your very human
beingness
if you let it and as a young girl from
rural mississippi i learned long ago
that
being myself was much easier than
pretending to be
barbara walters although when i first
started because i had barbara in my head
i would try to sit like barbara talk
like bob remove like barbara and then
one night i was on the news reading the
news and i called canada kanada and uh
that was the end of me being barbara i
cracked myself up on tv
couldn't stop laughing and my real
personality came through and i figured
out
oh gee i can be a much better oprah than
i could be a pretend
barbara rule number two hang out with
successful people with bill gates
there's no doubt that
uh you know creating a board having
people like dave marquart there
who wasn't at the company you know and
we were
so overwrought about you know this is
right this is wrong we messed this up
that having people have a little bit of
distance uh
come in and talk to us is good you know
for the last
uh oh 30 years or so
i've gotten to be friends with warren
buffett and he
he's in omaha uh he's not in this tech
world at all
you know and to him it's like hey how
could you ever know which
will rise and which will fall i'm not
going to put money
uh until apple sold at a multiple of 12.
then
he decided he could put 50 billion into
that
after he asked all his friends hey you
know if the if somebody had an
uh iphone that was half as expensive
would you switch away
you know or is it more like jewelry
where you really want uh
to to have an iphone and so he decided
that the
those profit streams might not be
eliminated anytime soon anyway he
because he's not in
this world he has a
a definite way of looking at things
including this idea of
how work should be fun he has made his
work so much fun
that he works more hours than i do
he works six days a week at 88 years old
and he likes to say that he skips to
work every day he he doesn't but
he says that when he was 83 he could
still skip but now he's done
really he can't do it so
having somebody like that you know the
toughest thing i went through was this
anti-trust lawsuit
where you know it didn't seem uh very
predictable
uh and he was a great counsel during
all of that stuff so getting somebody
who's in successful in another domain
uh but yet kind of a business
uh type mindset anyway for me that that
was a huge gift
rule number three ask the right
questions with elon musk
when i was in in high school i thought
i'd most likely be doing physics at a
particle accelerator
so that's what as
physics and computers i mean i got
distinctions in two areas in physics and
computer science and those were
yeah so my two best subjects and i
and then i thought okay well that i want
to figure out what's the nature of the
universe and
um so you know go try to
working with people banging particles
together to see what happens
um and um and then
these sort of things went along and the
the superconducting collider got
cancelled
in the us and that actually was like
whoa you know
what if i i'm working at a collider
i spent all these years and then the
government just canceled it wow
and then that would was like hoping i
can do that
so um so it's like
well we roll back a little um
like i tried to figure out when i was
killing i had like this existential
crisis and i was
about 12 years old or something and and
i was like
what does the world mean wait what's it
all about
are we living some meaningless existence
and and then um
i met i made the mistake of reading
nietzsche and chopin howard and
yes and i'm like wow
don't do that i'm not it's not it's not
a little older i think
now actually lately these days i still
rear it so like
you know it's actually he's not that bad
he's he's got issues he's got issues no
question about it
but but you know it's anyway um
so uh but then i read the hitchhiker's
guide to the galaxy douglas adams uh
which is like quite really quite a good
book in philosophy i think and i was
like
okay we don't really know what the
answer is
obviously uh so but the universe the
universe is the answer
and that really what are the questions
we should be asking to better understand
the nature of the universe
and so then to the degree that we expand
the scope and scale
of consciousness um then we'll better be
able to answer the
ask the questions um and understand
the why we're here or what what it's all
about
and so sort of take the set of actions
that
are most likely to result in us
understanding
what questions to ask about the nature
of the universe rule number four
set correct goals with grant cardone
what would you say is the best advice
that you could give other people from
what you learned about making their
first
million bucks so say somebody's making
six figures scaling up and that's just
do the math
you know what's what's first of all do
you want to make a million
or do you want to keep a million
they're completely they're like 60
percent difference between those two
questions right so specificity and the
goal
you want to make everybody's everybody
watching is going to make a million
dollars
i mean if you live 25 years you're going
to make a million dollars
25 times 40 000 bucks bang you made a
million dollars
if that's your goal so this is what i
talked about in the 10x rule the goals
people are setting are incorrect and
that's why people give up on their goals
because i know so many guys that hit a
million dollars
like i've had so many people come to me
and say i hit a million
and i lost the juice yeah it got
comfortable almost yeah a lot of guys in
network marketing tell me this
like i was in network marketing i became
a million dollar producer
just lost it because the goal was wrong
the goal was wrong first of all it
wasn't your goal anybody's got a million
dollar target it's not your goal
you adopted this goal this idea from
somebody else
because the number any number that ends
in zero is a lazy number
mm-hmm a number ending in zero
is almost mathematical what a great
point what a great point so it's a lazy
concept
you just adopted somebody else's idea i
want to be a millionaire
would do you have even done the math do
the math on a million dollars
it's no money this is why people they
they
like god hate grant because your target
was a million
you're struggling making 200. you think
a million is impossible
you don't want me to tell you the truth
and the truth is it is no money
as soon as you get it i read the book
the millionaire next door almost
everybody read that book back in the
90s it was the best book for me
because it taught me i don't want to be
a millionaire
it lifted the lid i'm like i don't want
to be the guy buying a ford truck
i don't want a ford truck man right i
got to buy a ford truck a used ford
truck
f-150 so one day i could be a
millionaire
yeah and i can't go get coffee i need to
bring a brown pack
to my office every day not drink coffee
at the shop
in order to be a millionaire well the
reason i knew that was not good for me
was because my dad died
at 52 with a little bit of money
and i'm like i don't want to die with
money when i'm old
i want to have enough money and that
that undid everything for me i want
financial freedom i don't want to hit a
quota
you know and i think everybody's
struggling for the quota they're
struggling for the bills they set their
financial plan based on
what their spending is or what their
apartment cost or what the mortgage is
rather or what their kids need rather
than i want freedom
i don't want financial literacy i want
financial freedom
you know so i hear people say oh we need
to teach financial literacy no you need
to teach financial freedom the
possibility of it what would i need
how much you know this whole cash flow
thing that i talk about all the time
cash flow is the holy grail of finance
that's why his business works that's why
he's able to enjoy the lifestyle he has
he has
financial freedom not a money number hey
man
how you doing buddy good how are you you
got a book coming out don't you
uh you just came out where can people
get it
get it on amazon easiest spot built to
serve
right there let's go man if you guys
don't know evan follow evan carmichael
he's got a new book out build a serve go
grab it today at amazon
there's a good dude right here rule
number five let rejection
fuel you with jamie curran lima what was
called beautiful
i didn't see myself in right and so i
had this whole idea
which is part of why all the retailers
were saying no in the early years i had
this idea
to not just create products that work
but let me show models all different
people
every age skin tone skin challenge
gender identity skin problem side like
let me just show real people
and prove this product works like let me
go on qvc and prove it live let me
show my own rosation i just thought if
people can see people look like them
this just makes sense to me but all the
experts said it didn't
so so back to me standing there with
this investor saying i don't think
people will buy makeup from someone who
looks like you
with your body and your weight after i
went in my car and cried
like it's rejection always still hurts
uh i also just remember feeling like wow
he's passing on investing in my business
on
he's making a business decision because
of exactly why i'm starting this company
like he's just as much
i don't want to call it a victim but
just as much impacted
by by the definition of beauty that's
out there
and he's literally passing on investing
in my company because of it
and so it drove my deep why for like
why i was building this company and i
took that rejection as
fuel for like oh this has got to change
right
and for me it was like let me build a
company
where we show all types of beauty where
where it wasn't even just about selling
product it wasn't about solving my own
problems and even though i want to help
millions of women and all that the real
why was like
can i shift culture and beauty um for
every little girl out there
who's about to start doubting herself
and every
grown person who still does and so like
that drive
fueled it and not being afraid of
rejection
is so huge and it's it's really huge for
women because it prevents a lot of
people from even trying
and it hurts it always sucks it never
feels fun
rule number six work on your attitude
with warren buffett
you both have several managers working
under you so i was wondering what are
some steps
that a new entrant into the job market
can take to accelerate their journey
towards an upper
level management position yeah well
one thing i will tell you that i didn't
realize when i was getting out of school
is how much
the unusual person will jump out
at you i mean you know and it isn't
because they got
200 iqs or anything like that it's
really because of just
how they behave you know what they bring
the energy they bring the commitment
they bring the
quality of how they do things how they
treat the people around them all kinds
of things but
you will jump out much more than you
might anticipate
one of the things you would want to be
sure to do
is whether you like it or not get very
comfortable it may take a while with
public speaking for example i mean that
that's a an asset that will last you 50
or 60 years and it's a liability if you
don't like doing it or uncomfortable
doing it that also
will last you 50 or 60 years and it's a
necessary skill
but a lot of the skills are just human
skills if you get the best out of people
around you
that's a rare talent and it it doesn't
it doesn't correlate with iq it
correlates with a
you know an attitude and toward the
world and toward other people and
it's a talent that if you work at early
and you're really conscious about it
you know you don't have to show up other
people you know you have to be smart in
there or anything
you want to bring out the best in them
it will pay huge dividends
and rule number seven the last one
before a very special bonus clip
is put your customers first with mark
cuban
people often ask me what it takes to
start a business
what is the key ingredient how did i how
did i start the business and
how did we grow to about 20 million
dollar 20 million dollars in sales so
quickly
you know they all come up with some new
whiz-bang idea they're gonna invent the
the better mouse trap they're gonna come
up with new software new hardware
and more often than not it seems like
they've spent their millions before they
they thought through their idea
but when we talk about new companies and
growth and success
there really is only one common
ingredient
across any type of business whether it's
oil or computers or software anything
and that key ingredient
is customers without customers
whether you're starting a business
running a business expanding a business
you don't have a business there is no
business customers
are the key ingredient to get those
profits
you gotta have the customers you gotta
have happy customers
that's the bottom line you know micro
solutions we've been we've been going
and growing
and it's impossible not to have growing
pains it's impossible not to make
mistakes
we screw up all the time and you know it
doesn't bother me as president
if i have a if i have an employee who
just didn't do something right
just made a mistake it's good because if
you're not making mistakes you're not
trying hard enough
you know these things i'm saying they're
not unique they're not things that i
just thought up in some
some miracle growth you know things when
i talk to people in our company when i
talk to people about our company
i never have a unique thought i can't
remember i don't know that i ever did i
can't remember if i ever will or don't
expect ever to
there's no magic formulas to customer
service there's no magic formulas to
doing things right
these these sayings that you hear me say
are things that i've read elsewhere and
just regurgitate that but how many
people do them
you know we all know the golden rule do
unto others
as you would have them do unto you and
that's nice
you know but do you do it but even more
importantly than the golden rule what
about the lover's rule
do on to others as you would love to
have them do unto you
that's what we try to stress that micro
solution that's what we try to use to
differentiate ourselves
not just to get by because everybody's
going to be nice
you know when you invite someone into
your house that is an acquaintance that
you like okay
you're gonna offer them coffee you're
gonna offer them a doughnut
and that's really what you expect you
know if you went to their house because
you're just acquaintances but when you
leave the house
it was nice if you go back fine if you
don't go back fine
that's the way customers look at
businesses if i go back fine
if i don't go back fine you know they
say that 80 percent of the people who
have a problem
tell at least 10 people only 10 percent
of the people who had a good experience
tell
anybody and it's the same way when you
go to visit
an acquaintance and when people come to
try to do business with micro solutions
i hope
i pray and i try to convey to each and
every one of our people
that we give them a reason to want to
come back
we give them a reason to do a good
morning rap to say okay let's do
business with micro solutions
you've got to really concentrate to do
unto others as you would love to have
them do unto you
now i've got a special bonus clip that i
think you're going to enjoy but before
that it's time for the question of the
day
i want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway from this video and
your plan of action for the next week
when you watch a video and you get
motivated the sign says you have a 35
chance of following through that's not
enough but when you write down what time
what place and how you're going to
actually take action on it
you jump to 91 chance of following
through and when you have public
accountability and you commit
to other people that you're gonna do it
it jumps to 95
that you will follow through so i want
that for you believe nation
i want to know your single biggest
takeaway from this video and your plan
of action for the next week
put it down in the comments below so i
can celebrate
you i think there's a problem in in
western europe where um
where failure is uh it's it's too
impossible to fail
once you fail you can never you can
never start over
i think there's a there's an opposite
version of this in california where i
think sometimes
people are a little bit too facile about
failure because i
i think it actually is always incredibly
damaging to people
um and if you work really hard at
something and it doesn't work
um uh that's you know that's
that's going to be psychologically
damaging you know
people have less confidence you there
all sorts of reasons why
why that tends to be uh that tends to be
quite bad i think that um
i think when people i don't think
there's that much you learn from failure
by the way
because um it's it's typically over
determined it's like why is technology
slowing down
why did you fail it's typically five
separate
reasons you worked with the wrong people
the idea was bad
the timing was wrong it wasn't a
monopoly the product didn't work
and okay next time i'm working with
different people you figure out one out
of the five things
you're likely to fail fail again so i
think i think
failure is not something one can learn
very much from i think that's sort of a
myth that i i would challenge um but
what i think
what i think you should do when you when
when something goes badly wrong is
um you just keep going uh you you do
something else
and you don't dwell on the past
[Music]
if you want even more insight into how
billionaires think check out the video
right there next to me i think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe
and i'll see you there i became
terrified of public speaking
and uh i just couldn't do it your
relationship with time
is such a key component of your life
because when you get caught in a routine
time goes so quickly